welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the guy who
wants to Ezra Miller chokeslam whoever
hired Joss Whedon - just kidding
but not really in the wake of Zack
Snyder's commentary on Batman V Superman
people are once more crying out for
Warner Brothers to release the Snyder
cut and it's easy to see why - since
2017 we've learned a ton of information
on the project and it sounds like the
film would have really been something
special Zack Snyder's Justice League was
trending on Twitter earlier in the week
and even three years after the release
of Justice League interest certainly
hasn't died down but what was meant to
happen in the film and why are so many
desperate to see it well throughout this
video we'll be going through the biggest
differences between the Snyder cut and
the theory cool release these include
Henry cavils mustache the role of
Darkseid in the film Green Lantern
Martian Manhunter and a lot more there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to check out
Justice League yet then I highly
recommend that you turn off now make
sure you subscribe to the channel for
videos like this every day and please
drop a thumbs up if you enjoy it without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our breakdown of the
biggest Snyder cut differences okay so
some of the biggest changes in the film
centered around the villain or rather
villains of the piece Lex Luthor
returned in a greater role which we'll
get into in just a bit but there were
also much more distinctive changes in
the forces of apocalypse not only was
Steppenwolf's designed completely
different in the final cut but the big
bad of the DC Universe Darkseid was also
set to feature prominently in the film
the movie was meant to open with the
invasion of Earth led by the character
who would go head-to-head with Ares this
would tie Wonder Woman into Justice
League and just flashed out the universe
a hell of a lot more instead we got the
opening credits which felt pretty meh
especially when we know how well it's
knighted as opening credits from
Watchmen though Darkseid failed and had
to retreat he still kick-started the
film as an intimidating figure that was
difficult to forget Steppenwolf also
looked more like his iteration from
Batman V Superman and he was to be a
relative of Darkseid
was gone to try and win back his favor
after the crushing defeat that they
suffered at the hands of earth he was
far more complicated and an intimidating
character that really put the fear into
the league instead of looking like a toy
made out of marshmallow recently Ciaran
Hinds who voiced the character spoke of
his disappointment with the final
release and said that wasn't the movie I
worked so hard on
we hoped the director's cut comes out
because it was better than the movie in
the theaters so it does seem like the
original Steppenwolf would have been
better than the one that we got but he
wasn't the only villain that was
simplified in the end result the mother
boxes themselves were to take on a far
more distinctive role and they would be
more like living entities rather than
plot devices the three boxes were meant
to represent fear alienation and doubt
these are the main emotions which the
planet was feeling at the time due to
the death of Superman this general
despair over earth helped to power them
and this was when we got the line from
the trailer there's no protectors here
no lanterns no Kryptonian Steppenwolf
was going to use these devices to
overwhelm the planet and this would set
up the anti-life equation which would
pay off in later movies the league was
supposedly going to spend a lot more
time install apps and this would be
where one of the big action scenes would
happen in order to retrieve one of the
mother boxes
Steppenwolf was going to show up and
take it from them directly Snyder has
shown a lot of this action scene and
though we don't know for definite it
does look like Silas stone was killed in
the bowel
so not only had Steppenwolf beaten them
under Gotham Harbor
he had also beaten them in their base
killed one of their allies and shown
firsthand that he was a threat that
needed to be taken seriously instead we
got him taking the mother box because
the league had forgotten that they left
it in a car park or something
his death was also meant to be a lot
different in the original cut
Wonderwoman beheaded the character as he
was trying to escape in a boom tube his
head rolled out on the other end and
Darkseid stopped it with his foot and
came face to face with the characters
starting their rivalry the movie ended
with Diana researching Darkseid and it
slowly put the pieces in place for him
to become the big bad of the DC Universe
as mentioned earlier lex was going to
feature more prominently and instead of
batman search
for parademons on rooftops he would
actually learn from Lex's journal which
he collected in the prior movie Jesse
Eisenberg stated that many of his scenes
were cut in the wrong room is that
Batman at one point returned to Arkham
to interrogate him this would drive him
to escape and overall he was far more
fleshed out another character that was
wholly underdeveloped was cyborg in the
final cut he received barely any setup
and was pretty much just plunked into it
Victor stone was originally a football
star and we got to see firsthand him
playing a game for Gotham Silas was
meant to attend but he was absent and
thus Victor was upset in the car home
with his mother they got into an
argument over his father putting work
before him the car crashed and Victor's
mother died and as we know Victor
himself was saved by his father and
experimented on it added a wealth of
complexities to their relationship and
even in the final battle cyborg would be
tormented by the ghosts of his parents
and also the human version of himself
which would make him realize what he'd
lost he would also have far more time
discovering his powers learning to fly
tapping into computer feeds and
deploying weapons making for this film
being an origin story for the character
the movie would have ended with cyborg
discovering a message for him left by
his father before his death and this
would have been the closing monologue
for the film adding far more emotion to
it flash to received a flash now back
story in which he saved
iris West from a car accident and then
chokeslam her and threw her to the floor
iris was completely removed from the
film and this not only set up her as a
love interest for feature movies but it
also showed flash discovering his
abilities the changes weren't just in
the visuals either but in the soundtrack
for the film itself after collaborating
with Hans Zimmer on Man of Steel and BBS
junkie XL was going to be the composer
for the film so the epic score from Man
of Steel and Batman V Superman would to
be laced throughout this film
however likely for tonal reasons Warner
Brothers appointed Danny Elfman to take
over the reins of the project Elfman had
so little time to work on it that he had
to bring back his Batman team and the
Christopher Reeve Superman won in order
to get things done and in the end the
score just really lacked the punches
that the other entries in the DCE you
had now for things that were kept the
same but was shot I don't think even
really a tiny one that Superman looks so
weird in the film because they had the
CGI out henry cavill 'he's a mustache
due to his contract on mission
impossible fall out it's really
distracting laughable and it completely
takes you out of the whole movie some
someone actually got paid to do this
however the fact that the weird-looking
upper lip appears so much throughout the
film showcases that pretty much all of
Superman's scenes were he shot this
means that large chunks of dialogue will
likely change as a lot of his moments in
the film just him standing around he was
also going to approach Alfred at one
point and he'd have a lot more lines of
dialogue in addition to all of this
Superman was going to be in his black
costume which is a nod to his
resurrection in the comic books with
this suit not appearing in Justice
League it seems like we no longer have a
proper opportunity to see him in the
black suit and it feels like a huge loss
for die-hard DC fans he wasn't the only
one who got major issues either as from
side by side images of the original
trailer and the eventual release we can
see that Bruce's initial talk with
Aquaman was also changed quite a bit
when Arthur leaves Bruce tanning this
moment was also redone and look at the
green screen that we got dear hey that
that is why he's shoot on location
Aquaman 2 received a ton of extra screen
time and he had a large part of his
backstory that involved Falco long
before he ever appeared in the solo film
for the character Mira was to going to
appear at the end of the movie and call
Arthur back to Atlantis which would have
caused set things up going forward the
scene in which Louis visits the Superman
memorial and heroes park was going to
feature more prominently with Marco
Clara aka Jimmy Olsen also appearing as
a security guard Olsen was going to say
to Lois hey you don't miss a day do you
which showcased her grief we would also
end the film with a couple of major
appearances - from some big DC heroes
Green Lantern would arrive on earth
after hearing of the attack on the
planet
and it would be revealed that general
Swanwick was actually martian manhunter
we'd only seen him and his human form
the entire time and this big twist and
bombshell was going to recontextualize
everything that we'd seen so far overall
it feels like the movie would have been
a DC fans dream and it's a shame that we
will likely never see it unless Warner
Brothers finally decide to release it
there's enough support there and I
really think it could do wonders but I
guess we're just gonna have to wait and
see now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the changes and if there's
any others that should have made the
list I know this didn't include
everything so make sure you drop them in
the comment section below if you want
something else to watch after this then
make sure you check out our full
breakdown of Zack Snyder's original plan
for the DC EU we go over everything from
Man of Steel all the way up to Justice
League part 3 so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate you and there's
a thank-you you get access to content
early if you want to come chat to us
after the show either follow us at
Definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below every
month we give away free movies to people
are subscribed to the channel and this
month you can win the Marvel phase 3
part 1 box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you sub
with notifications on the more videos
you comment on the more you have a
chance of winning
so please get involved the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of May
and the set will be shipped out from the
end whoever gets the prize so best of
luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace